[Applauso]
[Musica]
vi sembrano foto sbagliate no sono
giustissime mia figlia Aurora a due anni
prende un tablet e scatta un servizio
fotografico del nostro appartamento
il mondo visto a 80 cm
lo sguardo di un bambino il suo punto di
vista è una cosa molto importante perché
noi ce lo portiamo dietro per tutto il
resto della nostra vita
la stessa bambina qualche tempo prima
aveva solo sei mesi era seduta su un
divano un pomeriggio d'inverno il dito
in bocca una testa piena di Riccioli
Biondi
passa la sorella maggiore Nina 4 anni la
guarda e poi mi dice Mamma guarda Aurora
sembra proprio un orso vero
a me tutto mi sembra fuori che un orso
io scrivo favole e alle mie figlie nel
racconto tante c'è una favola scozzese
che si intitola riccioli d'oro e i tre
orsi e la storia di una famiglia di orsi
papà orso mamma orsa e piccolo orso che
una mattina prima di fare colazione
escono in cerca di mirtilli
Mentre sono fuori
riccioli d'oro si introduce a casa loro
vede tre tazze sul tavolo la più piccola
è la più saporita beve tutto poi si
sposta e trova tre sedie di tre misure
diverse quella piccola a pennello ci si
siede e ci si dondola Finché la rompe a
quel punto si sposta in camera da letto
trova tre letti quello più piccolo È
così comodo che come si sdraia si
addormenta
a quel punto gli orsi tornano a casa e
trovano che qualcuno ha bevuto tutto il
latte di piccolo orso ha rotto la sua
sedia e adesso dorme nel suo letto
gli orsi si avvicinano senza fare rumore
in quel momento la bambina
spalanca gli occhi li guarda Si spaventa
e scappa via
Beh è una favola un pochino
insignificante no Almeno vista dagli
occhi di un adulto
Tutto cambia se invece ci mettiamo nei
panni di piccolo orso
piccolo orso vive felice col suo papà e
la sua mamma non vuole estranei per casa
non sa che papà e mamma hanno progettato
di avere un fratellino
e così quando arriva la sorellina
beve tutto il suo latte rompi i suoi
giochi dorme nel suo letto piccolo orso
è un po' infastidito
Ma quale finale migliore che avvicinarsi
vedere la bambina che apre gli occhi si
spaventa scappa via e non la Videro mai
più
dal punto di vista di un bambino è un
lieto fine perfetto
Ma allora Nina mi sta dicendo che Aurora
è proprio quelle strane o che nessuno di
noi voleva ero mamma e perché mi dice
che sembra un orso
Beh nella testa di un bambino non c'è la
stessa scala valoriale che c'è nella
nostra o nella vostra testa no
gli adulti vedono le cose in un modo i
bambini in un altro Quindi orsi bambini
e palloncini Hanno tutti la stessa
dignità Se ci pensate sono tutti
possibili personaggi di una favola
per esempio la mia vicina di casa ha un
bambino che si chiama Luca Luca 6 anni
Lui è contentissimo perché papà gli ha
permesso di tenere una lumaca sul
balcone le ha perfino dato un nome la
chiamata Chiara
Chiara e la sua compagna di banco la
mamma dice Luca
potrebbe offendersi Luca è stupito Ma
chi la lumaca
tutti parlano tutti provano emozioni ci
avete fatto caso che questo mondo in cui
vivono i nostri bambini assomiglia
moltissimo al mondo delle favole che gli
raccontiamo
Ecco magari noi ce lo ricordiamo meno
però La buona notizia è che noi Quel
mondo lì lo conosciamo benissimo Ci
abbiamo abitato anche noi Io ho così
cominciato a scrivere favole per parlare
con i bambini un giorno mi contatta una
signora suo figlio Davide ha quattro
anni e ha un problema all'asilo e fa un
gioco bellissimo Si chiama scivolata nel
corridoio all'asilo c'è un lungo
corridoio di marmo lui corre fino a metà
si butta sulle ginocchia e scivola fino
in fondo alle maestre piace un po' meno
quindi dicono di non farlo lo sgridano
lo mettono in castigo alla fine chiamano
la mamma
la mamma e tutte le mattine dice Davide
Oggi non scivolare nel corridoio e lui
tutte le mattine promette mamma oggi non
scivolo
poi come vi immaginate vede quel
corridoio non riesce proprio a resistere
allora scrivo una favola e la storia di
una palla che rotola dondola scivola
vorrebbe stare ferma Ma non ci riesce
Poi però una macchinina mica sua
posteggia proprio a un lato e tra la
macina e la parete la palla per la prima
volta sta ferma Davide mi ascolta
attento mi dice mi piace questa favola
solo non ho capito una cosa
Ma perché la palla Deve stare ferma
Allora la favola non ha risolto il
problema No Davide ancora vuole
scivolare lungo il corridoio però ha
aperto un canale di comunicazione lui
per la prima volta riesce a farmi la
vera domanda che un po' come dire perché
un bambino di 4 anni non deve scivolare
lungo il corridoio
ogni tanto qualcuno mi dice Sì ma io non
devo parlare coi bambini i miei figli
sono cresciuti Oppure io parlo solo con
gli adulti
è uguale
qualche anno fa mi chiedono di andare a
raccontare una favola in un ospedale
pediatrico un sabato mattina io mi
presento e trovo un gruppetto di
pazienti dai due ai 17 anni poi
naturalmente mamme e papà nonni qualche
fratello
Cerco una favola da poter adattare a
tutti e comincia a raccontare dopo una
decina di minuti arriva l'infermiera
visita del medico tutti i bambini in
camera con un genitore la mia platea si
dimezza Io taccio
ma dopo un po' una nonna dice scusi non
è che andrebbe avanti con quella favola
io vedo proprio la bambina che esce da
lì richiamata dalla mia favola anche
sicuramente dal fatto di avere un
nipotino ricoverato
I bambini sono dentro di noi allora ho
iniziato a scrivere favole per i grandi
o forse dovrei dire per i piccoli che
vivono dentro i grandi e poi scopro che
a Milano Esiste lo spazio civico un
centro di aggregazione che offre
sportelli gratuiti al commercialista lo
psicologo l'avvocato Allora li contatto
scrivo una mail vorrei offrire uno
sportello gratuito per parlare il
linguaggio delle favole mi convocano
vado piena di speranza mi fa accomodare
una ragazza spagnola molto gentile mi
dice
non te lo possiamo dare lo sportello
perché
ma dice Guarda ne abbiamo parlato però
in effetti Noi siamo cresciuti benissimo
anche senza a che serve
Allora sono lì penso Vediamo se riesco a
farmi capire
le dico una cosa che vorrei provare a
dire anche a voi
torniamo indietro nella memoria nei
ricordi
torniamo a quella volta che abbiamo
fatto una cosa da bambini che non
dovevamo fare una cosa proibita una cosa
pietata una cosa pericolosa
tutti abbiamo fatto qualcosa di
pericoloso da bambini che sapevamo di
non dover fare
la ricordate Mercedes la mia
interlocutrice si ricorda bene adesso
arriviamo a sera quel giorno lì siamo
tornati a casa un po' preoccupati
abbiamo aperto la porta e casa era tutto
tranquillo con un certo sollievo ci
siamo accorti che nessuno sospettava
nulla e ci siamo detti ma papà e mamma
non sanno Mica tutto
Mercedes le dico Ti ricordi quando li
vedevi discutere sopra la tua testa e
pensavi questi due qua e quello che
succede qui nel mio mondo ma non mi
hanno la più pallida idea
mi ricordo benissimo
Ecco il linguaggio delle favole serve a
questo a far parlare Il mondo dei grandi
e il mondo dei piccoli
per sederci pensa un attimo e poi dice
Beh Chissà così e mi dà lo sportello
la cosa interessante che io non ho
convinto per sé io ho semplicemente
chiamato Mercedes piccola è stata lei
che ha fatto vedere a Mercedes grande
qualcosa di cui non si ricordava più
però una volta che la vista Eh beh non è
stato più possibile tornare indietro
sarebbe un po' come dire che abbiamo due
occhi due punti di vista Certo se ne
chiudiamo uno
vediamo benissimo lo stesso però non è
la stessa cosa no
E allora se volete parlare al cuore di
un adulto beh
raccontategli una favola
[Applauso]